all right you may have seen on our
social media ahead of Groundhog Day we
conducted a little social experiment and
our colleagues Sophie Louie and Chris
Galis coers of Global News at 6 they're
joining us in studio to discuss the
results yes and uh good morning to both
of you thanks for waking up early very
early I haven't finished the coffee yet
this bad but yes happy to be here yeah
so we we share the results on social
media we got a lot of response but we
figured we should give people the
backstory of of how this all came about
so sop you and I were just having a
conversation about wardrobe yeah so we
have in the back of the station we have
a um a dressing area like dressing rooms
for for all of the onair people and
we're renovating them cleaning them up
and so Sonia and I were just discussing
our clothes and you know we have so many
we have a lot of clothes and part of the
thing is we you know we're on air a lot
and so we feel like we have to mix it up
or sometimes we get emails yeah and I
think the comment was just well why
don't we just wear the same thing every
day and that was
the guy in Australia right the new Zer
in Australia that's right yeah he wore
the same suit and jacket Ensemble for a
month I think a year was it a year might
have been yeah for a long time knowing
that his co-anchor got all kinds of
comments about it whenever she doubled
up or wore the same thing so he felt
okay well let's just see what happens if
I do it and that same sort of thing kind
of played out for us the two of you
asked us to do something similar one
week Chris and I would wear the same
suit tie shirt everything for a week
straight and then it'll be your turn in
including Caitlyn and uh CH yeah and uh
the results were interesting um I think
we have a bit of b-roll of some of the
emails that we received um I think Chris
you said your wife didn't even notice no
she has the TV on every day at 6:00 and
watches at least a portion of the show
every day and finally after the week
that I did it I'm like hey babe did you
notice anything different about my
wardrobe this week and she's like no I
wore exactly the same thing every day
same thing I have family members that
watched did not notice they got one
single comment but then look at these
all these emails that
you I think it was on day two I walked
into The Newsroom and I could hear
people chatting about it that was the
the day that I repeated an outfit and um
and we didn't tell many people in the
mus no no we didn't and you know I think
for for myself um the most surprising or
maybe refreshing thing was that most of
the comments were actually positive or
just came from a place of curios
exactly so you would you know we get a
lot of nasty comments or we have I've
noticed they they've slowed down so
maybe that's our receptionist who's like
shielding me from she shelding Tak a lot
of ab for us but yes she does she
definitely does but um yeah most of the
comments I saw in regard to this
experiment were just curious um a couple
people said maybe we should get
increased allowances no I'm kidding not
going to argue with that was no of
course cuz it it is a great expense and
that that is a a thing it's a
requirement of the job and we all get
that but it's a significant portion of
income that goes to wardrobe and and
trying to keep it fresh we wanted to ask
a question why Society is so obsessed in
terms of women's appearance compared to
Men We want to bring in a the director
of Labor studies from SF your name is
Kendra Strauss who joins us through Zoom
thank you Kendra for join so what's your
reaction to
this and I'm sure it was a lot of fun
but in a sense the results are not
entirely surprising I mean I think we
know all of the ways you know that um
women are generally judged on appearance
in in ways that are different and more
extreme than men and that has real
implications in the workplace because I
think the the point about cost is a
really good one um you know the
requirement to look in a particular way
to be taken seriously at work has costs
both in terms of one's kind of ability
to progress in one's job but it's a huge
financial pressure as
well that's a really good point yeah and
the hair and the makeup there's there's
a lot that goes into time the cost of
time too oh absolutely like look at my
hair compared and Jason's hair like this
takes literally 2 minutes to do after I
step out of the shower and we know
that's not the case for you guys is uh
it is a huge consideration yeah and K do
you think attitudes will ever change or
is this how just how this
is I think it's a really interesting
finding um as was just commented on that
most viewers didn't make a kind of
negative judgment you know about the
fact that um the women's wardrobes
didn't change I think many women and
unions have fought for a long time to
change attitudes about women's
appearance in the workplace and we can
think about battles that have been
fought over things like uh the
requirement to wear high heels or the
requirement to wear you know
form-fitting clothes um these those
kinds of um you know uniforms tend to
affect women in particular in the
service industry and so I think that
there has been you know a long battle
for a long time you know for women not
to be judged on the basis of what they
wear or to be expected to wear clothes
um that reinforce the fact that their
appearance is the most important thing
about them so it does seem like we're
making progress but very slow SRA one
last question for you because one thing
that people pointed out was were there
more women that commented than men and
we don't have an exact tally but
anecdotally yes a lot more women
commented than men does that surprise
you at
all no I think that the other part of
this you know I don't think this this is
something we can blame entirely kind of
on one gender I think the fact is that
we're all socialized to believe that
women you know um have a responsibility
to kind of look a particular way to be
taken seriously um you know and women
and girls tend to be socialized into
being highly attuned to how we look and
how other people look and so that needs
to change as well you know this is this
is in a sense it's a a societal issue
not really just about women and men it's
really about gender Norms yeah Kendra
thank you so much for joining us and
lending your expertise because yeah it
was a a light-hearted experiment with
one with a strong message and reaction
very informative and interesting for us
and and a big thanks to viewers who were
cuz I did get a lot of people now that
cats out the b a lot of people said I
thought something was up but I just felt
that it was maybe not appropriate to
comment um so it's not that they didn't
notice that you and I were doing the
same thing they they were just feeling
that it was rude to to mention it not so
much for you guys to comment about you
and everyone like keenly observ it and
yeah and and the people who did write in
again they didn't say for the most part
negative things so appreciate and I
think for me the biggest takeaway is
I'll be repeating my clothes more often
yeah you know not having to think about
it all the time is so free so free
exactly next experiment uh no deodorant
for a week how about that not
participating that one at all all right
that was fun guys